previously on the wall how happened what
did you see could she see Jesus [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
I'll let you be Robin next time I'll let
you be Robin
all right here we go steady now oh yay
good job Cherie I need to cut it short
enough so that I can't get great yeah
look cute and a lot harder to gray and I
think that one buddy
what fool I was the one giving the
bandit supplies oh yeah and kill you
hi if I [ __ ] kill ya poor Kenny you
keep screaming like that you're gonna
get your face chewed off are you guys
gonna be trouble because we could have
just kept walking we won't let them
escape
alright hey how's the gun bruh milla
milla nama is Felicia know pretty bad
how the hell do I go up there alright
there we go
alright welcome bros the final apple
some up there
you better not be murderers or thieves I
guess you'll have to find out son like
you said [ __ ] them up
I don't know that's a word but you go
leave guys is what we need there what
you think we need I recognize this voice
for now what about when stopped hey dude
I'm Omid but some Omid Krista teres
we're driving it oh man alright so uh
it's been a bad day gonna [ __ ] you
our group is a little [ __ ] right now a
lot of people die in a bite victim then
his mom took a life and before that just
it's okay
oh [ __ ] goddamn you guys have a kid
oh that's Clemmy Clemmy what are you
doing here do you know how long it's
been since I've seen a kid [ __ ] what's
your name
Jaime Clara oh so he gets to swear oh I
guess it's great see things are looking
up you're not her dad he down there how
do you know that obvious to me no he's
not down there huh what's your story why
do you care well we just been trying to
get back been trying to get by together
maybe find her parents and everybody
down there they're cool
but Ben is a [ __ ] I just met chalk
Ken Eliza my bet is this [ __ ] young
and stupid
Ben's young and stupid and I think
harmless the first two things you said
don't really go with the third I know we
just have to keep an eye on him
that's why it's been rough for everybody
down there I'm sure you can say the same
we're sorry for anything that's happened
to you guys
the Train is awesome though a tank is a
real problem we'll help you with it but
if we see anything we don't like we're
moving on down the road
alone we'd appreciate the help you can't
just blast through it I guess if you
could get it down the rest would
probably be pretty easy we'll start
there we'll come down and settle in and
see if we can help all right all right
jolly good jolly good jolly good jolly
let's investigate over here some stop
signs we can smash zombies with these or
where the cones are a bra or boobies or
I don't know what is he doing it's Dutch
tasteful severe gotta love my Dutch day
generator can we do we can't do anything
what the jet there right up is too much
can we close no way I'm pulling anything
apart down there alright I guess we we
go down dudes hey Ben's reaction this is
old meeting mr. Ahmed okay GaN welcomes
like I said it's been a bit of a day we
just wanted to say hi and say your train
is pretty cool so not looking for
charity we're going to cut the tank
about tinker down and be on our way
there's a house back block plan enough
to me you want to start in on that
tanker I'll get to know the girl for a
minute if you don't mind I don't know if
I show you how this thing works case
something happens really kid it's
probably for the best
poor Kenny someone might want to have a
look inside of that station back there -
sounds great
let's do this thing
oh you got some music and then clammy
crew and we Sarah - scot-free the tanker
III III and I guess I'll just [ __ ] go
away and then we shared he wants you
don't like a little Graham but it's like
we're a team
ah yeah ah come on my son and I are
checking out this train station alright
hustle over if you hear anything all
right look at the flower
survivors inside my soul right zombies
inside damn bees inside that damn is
inside ain't nobody inside anymore girl
I suck lemme clue I don't even know
where to find some glue because I want
you what is this
and climbing on up in that you should
wait for me before trying to open door
exactly sorry could be dangerous luckily
it's locked
we'll get better working together
alright don't worry by climbing clue I
got you babe I got you babe to soap it
up there ah maybe I could look in
exactly you go girl
why don't I put you on my shoulders and
you can peek into that window up there
sounds good
Edd's do it you go Chloe clue I don't
even know why bad yell but I know how
long let me go what do I do now uh I
think getting the door open
no rope it's gonna be tough it might not
be that hard maybe we can find the key
figure out a way to knock this door down
can he probably have me picked a lock
which actually might worth nothing yeah
yeah me does it anything real
for reals oh man clams you rules good
girl plan will be there Holy Name rights
gun sign let's go be careful oh I wanted
to tell you that I mean yes he's backed
out whoa
creepy ah damn it's dark in here
maybe I can hold the door open I don't
like that I'll prop it open what's up
I guess we can find something and put it
there or would you output this
all right hikes Iwerks lemme clue I
don't know my yo but I know why bark
lemme clue was this that's exactly what
we need
ah come yeah we need to get in there and
get that blowtorch all right
how worked up good what about you
climbing you got an idea how we do it
good what do we need something to help
us deal with the taker out there nothing
that I just okay same same thing there's
some space up there but not butch we're
lucky ain't so little yeah we are
I don't know about this climber you
don't have to do it if you don't want
you okay going over the top of this
fence yeah definitely huh all right be
careful climbing gonna grab the keys
clam come on scoot scoot climbing what
he's behind me thank you son of a [ __ ]
hey I have a gun you need help
[ __ ] him oh [ __ ] this is bad
hey guys
ah that's as far Oh bras underwear
that's it
what oh [ __ ]
I never a the [ __ ] out of B ha ha huh
dude chill
clammy are you alright don't huh the
Clemmy [ __ ]
commie oh okay it's okay everything's
fine
clammy shot oh no what you didn't shoot
but she was scared
oh god baby I do oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] girl oh
[ __ ] alright alright alright I got this
I got this I got this uh like please
come on cut me open
get the [ __ ] away from her you son of a
[ __ ] it's for Jamie oh [ __ ] or Jamie
Oliver's extra body fat that didn't go
so good that worried by a clan who did
not go so good did not go everything's
okay
don't worry about Clemmy what's going on
I thought I heard a gunshot
welfare worry about it we found some
walkers
you and an eight-year-old versus three
of them huh yeah that's how we roll
where the Pew clenteen mind your
business
what did you to help out we would have
asked if you two were to die in here
three dead turns to five and that's my
business
good thing it didn't happen man I'm
gonna go make sure the noise didn't
cause us any problems that's a good idea
back gap how can he not like Lemmy don't
give me that stare I'll stay let me know
what you're doing with her I hope you
know that euros we're still alive are
doing live are we yeah you are Chris
ain't nobody you ok climbing club you
sure you ok yeah I'm a little shaky or
clammy or a little clammy
come here climate clear I wish I coulda
been do something nice for her like it's
the only bad things happening all the
time oh yeah we need that thing I forgot
stupid that's why we came let me just
grab that let's go outside now man let's
go I'm not ready for a gun oh yeah not
to be afraid climbing clear they should
have got us but we got there
you're right calcium is the thing kill
us
you want to stay all right clammy clay I
don't know why I'm a mad I know what
where the hell did I put that tank
probably in my back pocket bad pocket I
don't even know about it
let's go all right I don't know about me
but I know one bad yoke lemak law
doesn't even know I don't know
I've found a blowtorch in the station
shouldn't make quick work of the
coupling up there excellent I'll come up
there with you to have a look
you just want to check out my ass all
right
why don't we got other hey why don't we
got other companies the blowtorch and
butter touch and what should I call me
and Clemmy as a team clue I doesn't
really work clam die Khalid I the whole
source of leave you could turn it off
dude I don't want my eyebrows burned off
I think your eyebrows are pretty good so
I understand you'd add this oh the tape
I have cars poop to schools and better I
don't know about me but I know why my
clinic huh
alright that's crazy
look at it go I would be really careful
with that flame
Wow saved my life man this thing is
hanging by a thread the smallest cut and
it'll go you can't reach it now you
doing here hahaha the couplings out of
my reach
think it'll be within mine yeah no but
I'm gonna tangle you over that ledge
hell you are the hell I am you know God
your real son of a [ __ ] aren't you hey
don't call me man start cut got a beat
whoa whoa
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] they coming from
I bet Lily brought them we gotta go
Oh me [ __ ] cut I am it's going up
can they just go up the bridge what
petroleum I don't even know what daddy
go our climate climate fine come Oh Oh
what the hell do we do now we go a stir
oh no you can still go you know uh we
gotta jump
what no way do it No yeah all right at
4:00 today but if Dad it's got a crack
corn FFT smell in there what up dog
garbage your way I will you yeah oh no
all right I'm sorry
not an [ __ ] I swear to God I not mean
to do that oh [ __ ] he's gonna be angry
about that one Hey oh I'm sorry bruh
bruh bruh bruh bruh I'm sorry really
sorry
come I know
not me she's ready no uh-uh
you piece of [ __ ] she's a woman don't
you dude
it's kind of sexist to be honest I think
men and women are equal
but hey
ladies a me but guys we want to go here
train no I'm fine climbing for you okay
don't worry about it for yourself
my leg is spot we're fine Clementine
fine
all right that's pretty cool pretty cool
is that the ending
oh we're Robert Savannah cool never
heard of Savannah is it a real yeah it's
gonna be a real town so it's a big town
by the ocean
Oh inside it's a Kenny ah this Canyon is
family
I think it these yeah Kenny and his
family that's so sad
Oh duck is wearing a puffy on stop a
ribbon ik hell yeah so Savannah's east
coast or west coast we're fun to include
I should know this where's the Atlantic
oh god this is embarrassing that's not
the plan well it's ours she and I talked
it through yep she's got in too bad man
you mean nobody can take all this what
we have yep
what we're supposed to do it and clear
anymore give anything to go back to
fighting over the motel sign
me too poor Candyman I'll leave you to
your thoughts been through a lie all
been through a line she's out cool like
I've never seen huh
can't wait for unit into Savannah
Clementine I got your parents right here
and you be sure to find me well he wants
you to her time now what I need holy
[ __ ] I thought that [ __ ] thing was
broken so did I why [ __ ] was that he's
convinced Clementine that he has her
parents y'all might want to rethink your
plan whoa
interesting a very interesting all right
next time
can't be that bad once at the river you
want to get on a boat you want to wait
around till the walkers figure out we're
here I know I promised that we'd find
your parents
Savannah's more dangerous than I thought
it would be bark Lambie I don't know how
much longer he can keep on like this if
his leg gets any worse we're gonna have
to carry him early on Kenny don't say
that were you I'm getting out of the
street now the hell is this
answer me damn it so when were you gonna
tell us about the radio who have you
been talking to hey don't yell a little
clammy you come back here I'll kill you
you understand I will kill you whoa all
right
can't wait for episode 4 really glad
libros enjoy the series as much as I did
[ __ ] epic epic last place so far I
can't wait for next two episode anyway
lockup road if you enjoyed it subscribe
to come over today and I'll see you next
episode over lab if you want to leave a
suggestion what other game I should play
that is kind of similar or story based
lemon now I was thinking Fahrenheit but
I don't know yet anyway Southworth have
your power that wannabe right
do you know waster come on Bennett do
you know why we stopped the car that's
because you just